tedo crise et runje qui s'évade d'une
prison mais le suisse au conte est une
église
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mais cherchez pas de fric
temps vous mais l'hôtel et on lui a mis
des fritons aucun machines ont elles en
train de les manquer quoi pourquoi parce
qu'elles sont pesce c'est trop top 30
soirée très bonne s'effrite je peux vous
dire puisque sa douleur de la belgique
et la belgique elle est belle mais
cherrier va se passer plein de choses
dans cette émission virginie
ils ont tous préparé une blague et
désigner la meilleure bête je l'avais
nous battre sur les gens c'est vous et
pourquoi est ce que les français puis du
dos plus doux plus du dos parce qu'il
pète plus haut que leur cul au enora
aller un belge fait le trajet paris
limoges voiture
il faudrait déjà à l'heure sur la
connaître ok il prades auto stoppeuse en
minijupe celle ci commence à lui faire
du charme à l'entrée de llo le belge lui
feront la chambre par béguère en
changeant de vitesse la nana je regarde
droit dans les yeux et lui dit tu peux
aller plus loin tu sais et le belge
répond si tu veux je peux rouler jusqu'à
marseille je crois qu'on va pas tous les
faire
pourquoi les belges se promènent t-il
dans le désert avec m après quoi une
fenêtre
ouais on n'entend pas vous avez un
accent pour pouvoir l'ouvrir quand ils
ont chaud à l'éclair la boîte vocale la
face oui j'ai l'impression d'être nommé
soleil avec dans une classe en
difficulté mais sur des grues et de
glisser runje qui s'évade d'une prison
n'est pas elle aussi son comble alors
c'est aux prisonniers oui un français et
un belge à huriel français qui veut
s'évader il escalade un mur
et quand ils escaladent le mur il ya le
gardien qui me suivent alors alors le
français lui fait ici ses débuts voilà
bien votre atelier protégé ces
prisonniers qui sont en train de
s'évader d'une barre ovomaltine cède aux
pressions
le prisonnier avait tout à flacq sont
pas tous les accents régionaux
c'est quoi l'histoire déjà ces deux
prisonniers du prison vous allez nous la
faire des avancées de belges qui pendant
une station de ski une fois oui ils
veulent retrouver exactement le moniteur
que l'année précédente
donc ils vont par l'office de tourisme
est désormais qu on voudrait le même
moniteur que l'année passée mais qui dit
excusez moi et à mixer sans moniteur
dans la station comment voulez vous que
je retrouve votre moniteur
ah bah écoutez moi on sait pas pourtant
l'aiment bien celui-là mais vous vous
avez vous un petit signe distinctif
ah ben non c'est juste une chose ah mais
c'est que c'est une fois il avait deux
amies
il avait deux années à ben oui la v2 a
lu ça je peux vous le dire mais comment
vous le savez avait coûté chaque fois
qu'on allait quelque part il y avait
toujours quelqu'un qui disait tiens
voilà le mono avec ses deux trous du cul
c'est une voiture de belges évidemment
qu'il s'arrête au bol boulogne devant
une prostituée et le conducteur doit
c'est là que vous avez choisi un vrai et
le conducteur du monde sait combien
tarifa demoiselles et la peau situer ni
ses 205 en arrivant ipad pas de 250
devant et 350 derrière et avec deux
belges arrière mais pourquoi c'est
toujours plus cher pour nous la dernière
ces deux prisonniers en train de
s'évader d'une prison il ya un français
un belge au moment d'escalader le mur le
français fait du bruit à huriel gardien
qui lui qui va là le français fait miaou
et s'évade à laurianne belge qui suit
c'est son tour il fait du bruit aussi
alors qu'un gardien qui joue qui valent
à une baisse qui fait c'est encore
lochard
[Applaudissements]
voila voila quoi à quoi on réduit mon
pays et on embrasse tous les mèches
sinon y'a bon état des eaux
[Musique]